there's a lot of people around that I
see in the YouTube comments that I meet
in real life even old friends and family
that I used to be friends with who have
a broke bank and it's directly linked
with their knowledge and their
perspective on life so I wanted to share
10 things right now which will help you
be a millionaire and think like a
millionaire and the first thing is this
you can work hard in business you can
work hard in a career you can work hard
selling flipping cars but the first way
to get rich is to operate where big
money is taking place so for example one
of the reasons that I got into property
was because people are dropping a
hundred thousand pounds a million pounds
on a single transaction they're dropping
huge amounts of money in this space so
if I can get in the space where people
are dropping big money then I'm
positioned right where even if I just
make a one percent broker fee I'm I'm in
the right space where I can make a lot
of money if I was in the exact same
business but I was selling lemonade in
the street no one's spending more than a
couple pound lemonade so how are you
gonna get rich so the first thing is
play the big game get in the game where
the big players are the Ballers the
money makers and for me that was getting
in property that's the first thing
second thing is Outsource your entire
life
right don't do things that are mundane
like washing your car like cutting your
grass like paying your bills like going
through your post just doing ordinary
mundane stuff as soon as your business
begins to take off just a little bit
Outsource your entire life so that you
have more time to do the important stuff
namely make money that's step two number
three is become a master okay most
people
are not that good uh what they're at
their business okay most people tend to
be all around us they're you know
they're all right this they play a bit
of tennis a bit of bowling that they do
a bit of sales a bit of marketers if
you're in business you need to obsess
over what it is that you're doing and
become a master in that business so my
business is property and what I realized
is I realized that actually estate
agents don't even know that much about
property in fact damn even lawyers and
property conveyancers like they don't
know much about certain things and I
thought man I want to become a master
are in property investment I'm going to
become an absolute Master at it and um
and I'm going to turn my car into a mini
University I'm going to set up a podcast
and invite millionaires to come and meet
me to talk on my podcast but really I
just want to pick their brain and learn
because I want to become a master so
become a master in your Niche next
number four is you want to be a
millionaire develop a super thick skin
because on your pursuit of being a
millionaire you're gonna have people
that are going to be hating on you even
when you make it and you become a
millionaire multi-millionaire there's
going to be people that now start
talking about you you're going to lose
friends you're gonna have to make
difficult conversations
you're gonna have to pick up the phone
you're gonna have to get rid of bad
tenants hire bad staff and if you want
to be liked if your whole the way that
you live and think is I want to be liked
by everybody then you're gonna you're
gonna suck your business you'll be broke
forever and ever and you deserve to be
broke because you traded your riches for
being liked and being everybody's friend
so you've got to have a thick skin and
make tough phone calls take pressure
fire people evict people do what needs
to be done don't be a [__] and worried
to make difficult phone calls you're
never ever gonna make it in business
number five is be quick you have to be
quick in business quick-minded you know
when I sit out and I see people out for
dinner we're about to go out for dinner
now and we're on with my wife Amanda hey
how you doing Amanda by the way are you
enjoying this as well you learn a lot so
I hope so when I see people ordering
food right and they're spending five
minutes talking about what they're gonna
order
for me I just know that that person is
broke if someone's having to think about
oh do I want raspberry or cherry
cheesecake let me think about that
you've got it in business I say that I
don't know I'll be judging people we'll
be watching people order their food I'll
be like that person's broke that
person's broke I can tell they're broke
because of the way that they're spending
so much time thinking about what they're
going to order in business you have to
think quick you have to act quick you
have to get things done quick
um which brings me to 0.6 which is this
you want to be a multi-millionaire you
have to be extremely unpatient impatient
that's the word
um Gary vaynerchuk talks about the
importance of patience you know be
patient be patient be patient I am the
most impatient person I've ever met if I
want something doing I want it done fast
now quick and I can't think about
anything until it's done I'm just like
happy I'm impulsive and impatient and I
think that is actually my superpower
that's made me a multi-millionaire so
I'm not convinced about all this
nonsense about being
patient yeah sure you've got to think
about the long game 100 but be impatient
be quick be fast get things done if I'm
if I'm buying a property okay and it's
taking forever and this list is taking
forever I'm on the phone man I'm like
come on what's Happening I want things
done quick and then I motivate my team I
push things over the line you can't be
waiting around waiting and see what
happens and be successful in business
absolute nonsense uh next number seven
you got to be ruthless with your company
okay if you're hanging around broke
people
then you're going to be broke you've got
to be ruthless with who you hang around
with get in the right circles if your
mom is broke do not be taking Financial
advice from your mom it's it amazes me
how many people say to me oh Samuel my
mum said this my mom said they keep
talking about what the mum said or their
friend or their parents or their
relatives Dave down the pub I'm thinking
no one would take advice from me about
how to get a six-pack you know why
because I ain't got a six-pack it'd be
Madness for me to start telling you how
to get a six-pack when I got a six-pack
in the same way take people given
Financial guidance and advice when they
are not rich themselves it's just
Madness so if people hanging around you
are miserable if they're negative if
they're broke if they pull you down
because normally your friends want you
to win but they just don't want you to
win more than them and if they're not
winning the bar is so low be ruthless
don't talk to them block their numbers
block their calls I'm not saying if your
mom was broke never speak to her again
but maybe just speak to her for a couple
minutes instead of a couple hours you
know just be careful and mind full and
definitely don't talk to them about
business or money next number eight
expect problems
you're always going to have problems in
your life always your problem in your
business to begin with might be I'm
struggling to find a deal then you find
a deal guess what now you got a new
problem now your problem is going to be
how am I going to get the finance now
you get the finance now you got a new
problem now it's taking too long you're
always going to have a problem then you
buy the property now you're trying to
find tenants then you get a tenant then
you've got a bad tent now if you've got
a victim now the house goes up in value
and you're trying to work out a way to
not pay tax that's the ultimate problem
when you're making so much money you're
like no no how am I going to save on tax
but the point is this you're always
going to have problems in your business
so uh expect problems when you have a
problem don't be like oh man it's hard
the very definition of an entrepreneur
is someone that solves problems so
expect problems people message me and
they're like Samuel are you running any
um events or you know property training
courses I'm like yeah man I got
something going on in London and say ah
I live in Bedford it's like an hour and
a half away let me know when you've got
something in Bedford I'm thinking what
is wrong with this person people are
traveling all over the world jumping on
flights and stuff to come and learn and
be educated you can't even do a
90-minute trip you're so stoppable if
that's a problem to you guess what
everything's gonna be a problem to you
you're going to be a failed business
person so you've got to get really used
to dealing with problems when a problem
comes you've got to be able to cope with
the pressure it's very high pressure
business being in property being a
multi-millionaire having loads of staff
that work for you and all kinds of stuff
journalists write stories about you it's
quite pressure but everything's hard
it's hard having money and it's hard not
having money right it's hard having a
job it's hard having a business it's
hard having a six-pack I can assure you
I've not got one but I'm trying to get
one it's real hard we know it's also
hard being fat it's hard being married
not that hard knowing you're married to
Amanda but he's having mad it's also
hard being single hard not having kids
hard having kids everything's hard
choose your heart get over it and expect
problems all right next number nine is
be brutally honest
it's okay to make money it's okay to
want to make money if I'm sat trying to
negotiate a deal with with a seller and
they're saying oh you're negotiating a
bit too hard I'll tell them I'm proud I
said look man I gotta make money this
salad this is how I make my money this
is my business if I'm trying to do a
rent to rent and then I'll say no you're
going to make a lot of money from this I
was like it's brilliant isn't it yep
like be brutally honest I think people
appreciate honesty you haven't got to
lie or hide anything you know just be
brute in business be brutally honest and
be direct I love the fact that in
England business is done direct and then
finally number 10 last point hope you
enjoyed this video by the way make sure
you like the video make sure you share
it around make sure you drop a nice
comment make sure you come book to see
me as well come and spend a day with me
um depending on when you see this video
I'll leave a link hopefully what I've
expired by the time you see it just
check the link and maybe I'll be on tour
maybe I'll be near you book come see me
one pound I'm gonna do a one pound event
um last Point number ten
is
celebrate your success this is huge
celebrate every single win in business
and in life because when you celebrate a
win it puts you in a Winning State this
is why footballers celebrate so hard no
one scores a goal and then they just go
cool yeah I would have expected to score
a goal
that'll be strange the score goal the
new cartwheels they jump around
high-fiving each other now they don't
celebrate and Pat themselves on the back
for ages they'll celebrate hard but
they'll celebrate quick and then they'll
move back and get more goals done so
when you celebrate your success it puts
you in a Winning State so think about
all your successes that you've achieved
today celebrate them big maybe watch
this video over one more time take good
notes book to come and see me below at
the property investors crash course and
my name is Samuel Leeds I want to see
you win I want to see you win big